now to the discovery of those documents
Mark classified at locations linked to
President Biden and the serious
questions they raise Adriana Diaz looks
into what exactly the term classified
means and whether it really is common
for Pages like these to leave the White
House
Republicans want answers we need to know
who had access to those documents
including a list of who visited
President Biden's Wilmington home where
five more pages marked classified were
discovered last week the White House
counsel's office said in a statement
that there are no logs writing in part
like every president across Decades of
modern history his personal residence is
personal are these all the documents are
there more out there so far roughly 20
classified documents have been found at
Mr Biden's home and a former office that
the White House says were immediately
handed over to the national archives in
contrast to the FBI seized more than a
hundred documents from Mar-A-Lago in
August after former president Donald
Trump denied repeated requests to turn
them all over presidents and vice
presidents can take classified documents
home with little accounting of what they
have and where says former acting CIA
director Michael Morrell they're cut
slack because of who they are and I
think that that's what has to end
somebody needs to be put in charge of
knowing what information has gone to the
residents and making sure that that
information comes back Mary McCord who
oversaw the National Security division
at the Department of Justice says the
labeling is clear classified documents
have markings on them so that they would
be immediately identifiable as
classified there are three broad
classification levels confidential
secret and top secret depending on the
risk the intelligence if it gets out
poses to National Security the levels
are indicated on cover pages like these
from the Mar-A-Lago seizure and on the
top and bottom of each page as shown in
this mock-up and there's a wide range of
what can be considered classified we're
talking about military intelligence
we're talking about human sources we're
talking about nuclear related material I
think what is key here is less about
what types of things can be secret and
more about about the harm that these
things would cause to National Security
if they were disclosed
under the presidential records act what
is supposed to happen at the end of an
Administration is all government
documents belonging to a president or
vice president whether they're
classified or not are supposed to go to
the National Archives so one of the key
questions that special counsel will have
to determine here is why these documents
weren't at The Archives Nate
Adriana thank you